Thank You mr. president this is the
greatest honor of my life other than
Lynn agreeing to marry me 28 years ago
it's also the greatest gift I've ever
received except and there's another
caveat the birth of our daughters Jesse
and Becky as my parents taught me by
both words and deeds a life of public
service is as much a gift to the person
who serves as it is to those he is
serving and for me there could be no
higher public service than serving as a
member of the United States Supreme
Court my family deserves much of the
credit for the path that led me here
my grandparents left The Pale of
Settlement at the border of Western
Russia and Eastern Europe in the early
1900's fleeing anti-semitism and hoping
to make a better life for their children
in America they settled in the Midwest
eventually making their way to Chicago
there my father who ran the smallest of
small businesses from a room in our
basement took me with him as he made the
rounds to his customers always
impressing upon me the importance of
hard work and fair dealing there my
mother headed the local PTA and school
board and directed a volunteer services
agency all the while instilling in my
sisters and me the understanding that
service to the community is a
responsibility above all others even now
my sister's honor that example by
serving the children of their
communities I know that my mother is
watching this on television and crying
her eyes out
so are my sisters when I've supported me
in every step I have ever taken I only
wish that my father were here to see
this today
I also wish that we hadn't taught my
older daughter to be so adventurous that
she would be hiking in the mountains out
of self-service range when the president
called it was the sense of
responsibility to serve the community
instilled by my parents that led me to
leave my law firm to become a line
prosecutor in 1989 there one of my first
assignments was to assist in the
prosecution of a violent gang that had
come down to the district from New York
took over a public housing project and
terrorized the residents the hardest job
we faced was persuading mothers and
grandmothers but if they testified we
would be able to keep them safe and
convict the gang members we succeeded
only by convincing witnesses and victims
that they could trust that the rule of
law would prevail years later when I
went to Oklahoma City to investigate the
bombing of the Federal Building I saw up
close the devastation that can happen
when someone abandons the justice system
system
as a way of resolving grievances and
instead takes matters into his own hands
once again I saw the importance of
assuring victims and families that the
justice system could work we promised
that we would find the perpetrators that
we would bring them to justice and that
we would do it in a way that honored the
Constitution the people of Oklahoma City
gave us their trust and we did
everything we could to live up to it
trust that justice will be done in our
courts without prejudice or partisanship
is what in a large part distinguishes
this country from others people must be
confident that a judge's decisions are
determined by the law and only the law
for a judge to be worthy of such trust
he or she must be faithful to the
Constitution and to the statues passed
by the Congress he or she must put aside
his personal views or preferences and
follow the law not make it fidelity to
the Constitution and the law has been
the cornerstone of my professional life
and it's the hallmark of the kind of
judge I have tried to be for the past 18
years if the Senate sees fit to confer
me to the position for which I've been
nominated today I promise to continue on
that course mr. president
it's a great privilege to be nominated
by a fellow Chicagoan
I am grateful beyond words for the honor
you have bestowed upon me